Speaker 1: Let's try Nicholas from
Switzerland, one of my favorite countries.
Nicholas from Switzerland.
Speaker 9: Hey, I'm glad
you're doing fine. So can you hear me OK?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can. We're in Switzerland.
Are you calling from?
Speaker 9: I'm
calling from Zurich.
Speaker 1: Oh,
I love it. I love Zurich. What a great account
Speaker 9: is, Eric. Yeah, it's it's great. Yes.
So I've been watching your channel and other U.S.
politics news for some years now, and what I've
noticed is that getting anything progressive
to progress is almost impossible. I feel like.
Any anything good? It's almost impossible
to get through any legislation,
Speaker 1: and it feels like we're always
talking about the same things and it's like,
can we get them down or overall? We're
clearly getting nothing done if we keep
asking for the same things, right?
Speaker 9: Yes, exactly. And so what
I was wondering recently, I went to
a job interview and they asked me,
Where do I see myself in like 20 years, OK?
And I've thought about it, and I thought it
was really hard. But I wanted to ask you, where
do you see the US in 20 years? You know, in
terms of progressive policies and social changes,
Speaker 1: I think that number one, things change
so quickly. And number two, humans are terrible
at predicting things that I don't even waste
time thinking about something like that. It's sort
of like when people say, Where do you imagine your
show will be in five years? I say, I have no idea.
I have a plan for this year and I have a plan for
next year and five years ago. If anyone and people
did say, Where do you see the show in five years,
nothing I imagined is actually what's going
on right now. So here's what I would say. Even
though we're generally always talking about the
same things, we've got to raise the minimum wage,
we've got to provide health care, we've got
to reduce income inequality, we've got to deal
with the environment. When you look year by year
or over a few years, things are happening. The
minimum wage is going up. Although too slowly,
more people have health care today than have in
a long time, although not nearly enough and it's
not affordable enough. We are getting closer to
getting off of the gasoline powered vehicles
and closer to electric. So I think it's very
easy to get really bummed out because we
aren't going quickly enough. I agree. But
there is also progress being made. Twenty years,
it's too long to make any reasonable prediction.
It would be of no value for me to predict.
Speaker 9: OK. And do you think like over time,
Congress will get more or less functional?
Speaker 1: That's a really good question,
I I worry it will not get more functional, let's
put it that way. It might not be less functional,
but I'm worried it's not going to get any
more functional anytime soon. That's a
prediction I'm willing to make.
Speaker 9: Okay, great. Yeah,
yeah, that's about it. Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: How's the weather in Zurich these days?
Speaker 9: It's it's getting cold, really, but
it's it's nice. We have clear skies all day.
And yeah, except except for
the temperature, it's perfect.
Speaker 1: How cold does it get in
winter in Zurich, like in January?
Speaker 9: Oh, it really depends on the year,
but it's not that cold. Like in the morning,
it would get like minus minus seven, maybe
Speaker 1: OK, minus seven Celsius
Speaker 9: Celsius. Yeah,
we don't do imperial here.
Speaker 1: And how much snow do you guys get?
Speaker 9: There's also really depends,
I mean, luckily in Switzerland, you can
always go to like colorblind and or valleys
and go into the mountain mountains and go skiing
there, there's almost snow all here, there.
And during the winter, for sure. But here
in Zurich, it really depends on the year.
Sometimes we never get snow, sometimes we get snow
like all year, right? But if it can go from like
five centimeters up to like 30 was,
I think the max like we ever had
Speaker 1: here for the
entire season or per storm.
Speaker 9: No, no, no, it's there
would be like one big snowstorm I
snow for a couple of days and there would
be like 10 centimeters for maybe a month.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. Got it.
Well, it's a fan. Do you like living in
Switzerland? I've enjoyed my time there so much.
Speaker 9: Yeah, I mean, it's really great here.
I mean, standard, a standard of living is like
outstanding, of course. And we have to have a
school has been great for me. I've I've enjoyed so
many opportunities to do whatever I wanted to do.
Yeah, I really like it here.
Speaker 1: Fantastic. Well,
congratulations on living in Switzerland,
and I really appreciate the call.
Thank you very much. All right. Very good.
There is Nicholas from Switzerland. All right.
That's all the time I have for today. We'll take
a break. We'll get to your emails momentarily,
and we will take live calls again very soon
before you know it will be speaking again.